and activists who tried to climb the
Statue of Liberty is expected in court
this morning after her fourth of July
protests forced police to shut down
historic site for hours officials say
the suspect identified as therese o
Kemal was protesting the separation of
undocumented immigrant families at the
us-mexico border she was apprehended at
the foot of the statue more than a
hundred and fifty feet above ground
DeMarco Morgan is near Liberty Island at
New York Harbor de março good morning
good morning guys welcome I first
arrived on Liberty Island earlier in the
day with an activist group known as rise
and resist but it wasn't until after
seven of its members were arrested and
placed into custody for putting up a
banner that read abolish ice called him
for the abolition of ice that she began
her climb the standoff began just after
3:00 p.m. when Park officials first
noticed therese o Kamau at the feet of
Lady Liberty at first she wasn't
friendly with us but we took our time to
basically get a dialogue with her and
get a rapport with her she would trust
us o kamau appeared ready to climb
higher to avoid capture it took nearly
four hours before she eventually turned
herself over to the NYPD her actions
forced officials to evacuate four to
half thousand people everyone was taken
off the island
Jerry Willis says the public affairs
officer at the Statue of Liberty
he says okema began her climb from the
publicly accessible observation deck she
scaled more than 20 feet of the smooth
stone pedestal a stunt Willis claims has
never been attempted it's a vertical
climb and there's not many footholds or
anything so she she had either some good
skills or some dumb luck o Kemal herself
is an immigrant from the Democratic
Republic of the Congo she had arrived at
the monument earlier in the day with an
activist group known as rise and resist
it never occurred to us that someone
that we knew would attempt and
accomplish something like this that
gaudino is with the group she says oka
Mouse protest was not planned that took
a lot of courage and that was a very
daring action I understand why she
didn't let us know that she was doing
this because I think if this is an
action that was brought for
in front of the group for a decision we
probably would have voted it down as
being way too risky now the National
Park Service says it will examine the
incident and see if any additional
security measures need to be put in
place to make sure something like this
doesn't happen again
Kokomo is facing trespassing charges
among others Liana DeMarco thank you and
stay safe on that boat quite a live shot
there